once you install Android studio you can
open it and check for updates before
proceeding looks like we have the latest
version installed already so we can
close this dialog we're going to be
setting up a new project using Android
studio version 1.01
as you follow along if things look
differently on your computer that's okay
it's probably because you're on a newer
version of Android studio for the most
up-to-date instructions on how to get
started you can always check the
instructor notes below now let's click
here to start a new Android studio
project in the project wizard we set the
app name to be sunshine then we provide
a corresponding package name the package
name should be globally unique across
all packages installed on Android to
avoid conflicts use a reverse of the
name of the Internet domain that you own
this follows the Java package name
conventions we are using the commlite
example namespace for our sunshine app
because of the sample but you cannot
publish an app on Google Play with that
namespace usually leaving the default
package name is fine however this course
was originally filmed with an older
version of Android studio where the
module name app was included by default
so we'll edit the package name here so
it matches what we had in the older
version of Android studio for your code
to match the rest of the code in this
course you should add the dot app as
well next we choose our project location
and then we can hit next now we need to
choose our minimum SDK version in
previous versions of Android studio you
would also have to select the target SDK
now the project wizard automatically
sets the target SDK to the latest
version of Android even though it's
already selected for you it's important
to know the distinction between minimum
and target SDK